daredevil season 2 has been released on
Netflix and I apologize that I'm not as
fast as everyone in regards to binging
seasons of shows I like to appreciate it
I like to watch it and I like to focus
on it I find that when I binge things or
watch like a ton of episodes in one day
I miss things I don't appreciate it as
much I like to sit and I like to think
about it I like to stew about it a
little bit and that's why it took me a
little bit longer to watch all of
daredevil season 2 and for that reason I
am going to talk about a few spoilers in
regards to this season because I'm
assuming that most of you have seen it
if you have not seen season one or
season two of daredevil I implore you
check it out
this season introduced us to the
Punisher played by Jon Bernthal as well
as the character of Elektra it also
explores the hand this group of ninjas
who are hell-bent on something we're a
little unsure exactly about what it is
so this is something that Matt Murdock
blind lawyer turned superhero daredevil
is investigating along with his friends
foggy Nelson who is also a lawyer who
does know his secret and Karen Paige who
works at their firm who doesn't yet know
Matt's secret season 1 was close to
perfect it had incredible action
sequences it had a grounded story it
felt dark it felt realistic in all the
right ways it was violent it was gritty
it was adult I loved it season 2 I also
loved it's not quite as good as season 1
for one particular storyline I didn't
really enjoy the Elektra storyline there
were times where it was very very rocky
the first four episodes of season 2 were
almost perfect if not perfect everything
has flaws and blah blah blah but for
what it was the first four episodes of
season two floored me the introduction
to the Punisher played by Jon Bernthal
is so magnificent and having seen the
other incarnations of the Punisher I am
absolutely positive that Jon Bernthal
has made this role his own what he did
here is just unprecedented he is so
emotional you understand where he's
coming from you don't necessarily
condone his actions but you understand
why he thinks these actions are
necessary and that's what's so important
about the writing in this show
which is once again
incredibly strong they've crafted a
character in The Punisher along with Jon
Bernthal is amazing performance that is
so inherently evil yet we care about him
because we know the crazy that's
happened him in his past and it's also
his interplay with daredevil that was so
strong there's a scene in Episode four
in a graveyard that is one of the best
scenes I've ever seen a TV show these
two different ideologies with these two
characters clashing is one of the most
fascinating elements of season two now
episode two in season one cut man had
that amazing hallway fight sequence that
I did not think they were going to be
able to top episode three topped it this
stairwell fight blew me away and there's
this incredible moment right before it
starts where daredevil has this gun
taped to his hand he was being forced to
possibly kill somebody by The Punisher
but he knows there's no bullets left
because of the weight and the gun he
clicks it at the enemies they get scared
for a second and he just goes and then
takes a chain whips out a light and just
starts taking all these men out it was
amazing it sent chills down my spine
I immediately rewatched it what they did
with the action sequences and the way
they're held the choreography the stunt
work everything was an improvement on
the first season which was already
amazing in regards to action I am so
incredibly pleased with the way they're
doing the action in this show they're
doing it so right in the storyline
between foggy Matt and Karen was also
really strong here they all had
interesting things to do matt was
dealing with Electress presence while
also having feelings for Karen foggy had
to muster up the energy to deal with the
Punisher case without Matt's help all
characters were given really great
storylines in this season except for
Elektra not a big fan of Elektra she was
fine there were moments where I thought
she was a badass and really cool but she
was too almost bipolar in this season
she went from all these highs and lows
emotionally and I think they finally got
her right in the last couple episodes
for me I really like the way they took
her character in the last few episodes
kind of teaming up with Matt against the
hand and I love that but her character
was just too often on and there was this
really cheesy way of her finding her to
size with this random assassin sent to
kill her somewhere and it just felt very
convenient and it's really just Elektra
storyline in season two that felt
consistent for me the rest of it was
very strong I love Matt once again his
consistent struggle to maintain this
persona while not being a murderer as
well as the brilliant performance by
Charlie Cox I think he's fantastic he is
an amazing Matt Murdock and a fantastic
daredevil I love the costume as well
because they improved it in this season
they had a sort of dark night wave
improving the costume we're in The Dark
Knight Batman was attacked by those dogs
and it was like we need to be stronger
in a tape from these dogs these dogs
right they're killing me Alfred in this
season he gets shot in the face and he
feels like his mask isn't strong enough
because it cracks so they make him a new
mask and his costume looks so much
better because that was one of my only
complaints with season 1 his actual
daredevil costume was not that great it
didn't look as good as it could be they
improved it in spades in season 2
they've heard everyone's complaints and
it looks amazing
the action is fantastic the characters
are well-rounded there's very good
storylines this time around my favorite
part of season two is Jon Bernthal he's
amazing as the punisher totally worth
Golden Globes and Emmys and whatever
Awards television show actors can have
my only issue with season two is the
Elektra storyline along with this black
sky element with the hand there's this
thing that they feel they need and she's
the black sky or somebody's the black
sky we don't know what the black sky is
if you haven't read all the comics this
can get a little confusing but the thing
is now that they know season 1 was
successful and critics liked it and
people liked it that was a very
contained season that season had closure
and finality so if no one liked it they
wouldn't have had to make a season 2 but
everyone did now they know everyone
likes it they can take chances with
season two and have cliffhangers and
more strange storylines without all the
answers so I have a feeling we're going
to get more answers in season 3 guys I
love daredevil season 2 except for that
one Elektra storyline not being as
strong as it could be I'm going to give
it an A - if you haven't seen it I would
strongly strongly suggest it it's on
Netflix now guys if you notice this
background something I'm very excited
about this Sunday my retro rewind I'm
working very hard to make it very
special it's going to be all about old
movie rental stores like blockbuster or
Hollywood video I'm going to talk about
some of the stores that are still around
today like family video on the East
Coast
and my wife and I actually went to one
of the last remaining blockbusters in
the United States of America and filmed
inside of it we really wanted to make
this video special and I can't wait to
bring that to you guys it's going to be
this Sunday guys thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
Minh heist